but i i i literally have never lost a  game in fifa okay but i mean this is not  true okay you know you know i have have  you seen me lose one in your entire time  knowing me we do a thing where we play  golden goal it's the first person to  score wins what does the winner get what  are the stakes i get arsenal you don't  have to sell in the arsenal i don't own  awesome yeah you do you own arsenal and  you're gonna sell it you have to sell me  okay which one is shoot which one is  shoot which one is yours which one is go  turbo go turbo oh god like you see how i  just crossed the  out of here again give me that  do not try me ever a few moments later  no that doesn't count that's not easy